now and we do continue to follow that
breaking news a tour bus
from las vegas as you can see has
crashed in the state of arizona
brian officials telling us one person is
dead and dozens are hurt
take a look at the scene this happened
on diamond bar road this is on the way
to grand canyon west
david charns has been following the
story throughout the afternoon he joins
us now live in the newsroom david
and denise i do have some updated
information for you there were 48 people
on board this bus on its way
from las vegas to their grand canyon
take a look at that photo once again
from the scene you see the bus there on
its side in the middle of the road
you also see the emergency hatch open on
the middle of the bus at the bottom of
your screen and of course
lots of first responders there this is
where it happened on diamond bar road
about a two hour drive from where we are
in the valley
it's how you get to what's called grand
canyon west and if you're familiar with
that area
it's the attraction where you can walk
out on the skywalk
and then see to the bottom of the canyon
through some glass there now right now
this is what we know these are some
updated numbers 48 people
on this bus including the driver at
least one person has died
two people airlifted to a hospital here
in the valley three others
have serious injuries the rest were
minor and 44 people
including those numbers i just told you
were taken to king
king kingman that is regional with those
minor injuries again
48 people on this bus in all now right
now we don't know the name of the local
company that
runs this tour we are working to bring
you more information both on air and
online and we do have a crew headed to
the scene right now
i'm david sharon 8 news now